let's go back to streets as a mother the
bonus track on that is calling out names
which was
another one of those songs that i was
[ __ ] d [ __ ] m only x i know
is exhibitor rbx extraordinary you can
had a [ __ ] anyway
i know the song by heart love that song
dmx is like my as you can see i have dmx
behind you here you know dmx was a huge
he's watching i love x man you might be
watching me um but take me back to that
that feud between you and x obviously
you know he passed away uh earlier this
year yeah um
it was over your ex
or what was what is that what it was
yeah you know it was uh
i was in my feelings
and i was really just upset the whole
experience with this young lady
and just upset period
at the way i was being treated
being with this young lady you know and
just let off some steam throughout the
time of being with her certain
individuals
you know people will pump you up if you
allow them to
if you let them
and like you know i could say that a lot
of people
you know told me things that i took to
heart that this person was saying this
and this person said that in this
magazine this person said that
dmx was just a straw
that broke the camel's back
you know what i'm saying to where my
anger was
and so then i just um
i just let it all go
you know dmx is the main thing everybody
concentrates on but
i don't really talk about murder inc
and when we talk about
the rough riders and the whole
or
the firm
you know what i'm saying and everybody
else that i spoke on oh yeah you you
yeah max is the main thing they speak
you had a lot you had a lot of stuff
yeah i mean in the situation you loaded
up for a lot of people 80 right you know
what i'm saying so
but there was a lot of different people
i was upset at and angry about
uh things that went on or what i heard
right
i bought the carpet for the horse
you know and
really you know things like this you
talk to people man to man you really
don't
voice it through the music
you know what i mean
you know uh the way i was group i grew
up you know
if you really want to smash somebody
beat them up first and then you can talk
about them right you know
but don't talk about them first
you know and i i was just really angry